[Música]
ustedes creen que viven en democracia
a pesar de no la mayoría seguramente
diría que sí
pero si les hago una pregunta respecto a
que si en una democracia la mayor
cantidad de prácticas son verdaderamente
democráticas
créanme ahí la cosa se pone un poquito
más heavy
como consultor como académico dedicado a
la comunicación política investigo viajó
enseño recorro y corro américa latina a
cerca de 300 días al año y cuando hablo
de correr' hablo de correr' en serio en
las ciudades a la madrugada cuando uno
ve las ciudades desnudas vacías con los
rostros del espacio público ahí expuesto
y también tengo la oportunidad de
charlar con la gente y también la
tentación de interpretar de creer que
conozco lo que piensa en la gente por
ejemplo que siente orgullo de ser parte
qué se siente ciudadana ciudadano
que más allá del humor de turno con sus
gobernantes se siente feliz de ser parte
de un país
pero hace poco
algo me cambio
filmaba un documental en una favela
pacificada en san pablo brasil y hace
una entrevista a una líder barrial
y le preguntaba concretamente si sentía
orgullo de ser brasilera su rostro
cambió
me mira
con lágrimas en sus ojos
y me dice no
nosotros somos otra cosa
nosotros somos brasileros pobres
y eso me pegó duro
podrían sentir orgullo de ser parte
solamente cuando se jugaba un campeonato
de fútbol o frente alguna actividad
deportiva
pero hasta ahí nomás y me di cuenta que
mi concepción respondía a inercias de
cosas que naturalizamos que las tomamos
como verdad pero que no son así
y me pregunto cómo hay gente que pueda
vivir en semejante incomodidad y me
pregunto y les pregunto
si hay ignorancia y hay desconocimiento
en general
por lo tanto es desde ahí desde esas
inercias
que empecé a querer batallar contra una
en particular en el área en la que
trabajo en la comunicación política
particularmente en la comunicación que
viene del estado de arriba hacia abajo
descendente de un estado que es mucho
más que potente es avasallante en su voz
y cuando digo de arriba hacia abajo
por ejemplo en el estudio govern out a
que me tocó dirigir en toda américa
latina
analizando 1.200.000 interacciones de
los ciudadanos con sus gobiernos
solamente los gobiernos respondieron al
10 por ciento de ellas lo doy vuelta en
nueve de cada diez interacciones los
gobiernos enmudecieron
me tomé el trabajo de analizar por caso
es la totalidad de gobernadores y
gobernadores en argentina en un mes
calendario sobre la interacción en
twitter con la ciudadanía
saben cuál fue el resultado tomen nota
000 por ciento por lo tanto los
gobiernos monologan
y es desde ahí entonces en donde es
necesario comprender el rol del estado
que a mí me encanta un estado presente
activo promotor pero no un estado que se
mueva por inercias con monólogos que
reproduce practicas monárquicas o cuasi
monárquicas de siglos atrás hoy en plena
democracia
usamos una expresión en ciencia política
y les llamamos cesarismo que tiene que
ver con la violencia del control de
armas eso lo saco no tiene que ver con
el hoy democrático sin embargo hay una
parte que si está plenamente vigente y
es el culto al liderazgo
es una fe religiosa depositada en los
líderes es una atribución casi mítica en
creer que ellos o ellas
pueden solucionar crisis incluso
hurguemos un poquito más el francés
michel foucault utilizó una palabra
gubernamentalidad es una expresión que
denota relaciones asimétricas del poder
del gobierno por sobre todos los otros
poderes
y esa simetría se da en un dominio poco
claro oscuro semi oscuro vidrioso
entonces es necesario imaginar que hacen
falta algunos límites y conociendo estas
inercias me pregunto
si saberlas entenderlas y no hacer algo
no forma parte de una hipocresía
personal y por lo tanto en la pregunta
que surgió es que hago con estas
inercias y ahí se me ocurre que hay como
mínimo cuatro acciones que pueden
generar cambios o micro cambios da lo
mismo todo importa
por ejemplo revisar los protocolos
es lo primero charlaba con el ex
presidente en una larga charla pepe
mujica el ex presidente uruguayo y le
preguntaba hipotéticamente si él
volviese a ser presidente desde la
comunicación que es lo que haría y él me
dijo revisar los protocolos en general
él aludía al discurso diplomático donde
la política habla mucho y dice
prácticamente nada en argentina sería
sin embargo los protocolos reproducen
una herencia colonial que separa la
autoridad por un lado y el común de la
gente por el otro jerarquía y pueblo
ustedes notarán en cualquier acto
público si este por ejemplo fuese un
acto oficial generalmente la política se
saluda a sí misma a sus padres a su
jerarquías y luego si se acuerda y
siempre el último a ustedes la
ciudadanía el pueblo
el protocolo reproduce la verticalidad
reproduce la autoridad
sin embargo no toda es mala noticia
desde 1945 por caso y por decisión
protocolar perú estableció una norma en
donde ninguna dependencia pública puede
tener una foto de algún funcionario en
ejercicio y me gusta
pero ni siquiera hace falta la legalidad
zelinski el nuevo presidente de ucrania
antes de asumir reunió a sus servidores
públicos y les dijo concretamente no
pongan mi foto no soy un ídolo ni un
icono ni un retrato más bien coloquen la
foto de sus hijos
y mírenlos cada vez que tienen que tomar
una decisión difícil
en segundo lugar
el control del abuso de la
personalización poquísimo tiene
democrático
cuando un gobernante se apropia de la
publicidad oficial y abusa de ellas
decidiendo cómo y cuándo invertir
gastando millones en marcas de gobierno
para su propio beneficio ustedes verán
seguramente estos publicitarios donde
aparece la política en gerundio
inaugurando hablando visitando charlando
y luego es secundario a la propia
política pública inaugurada la obra el
servicio ese es el ego y luego es un
tema serio en la política
un gobernante tras diez años y tres
periodos ensaya un eslogan diez años de
gobernación lo mejor está por venir
fantástico fabuloso había que esperar
diez años y tres periodos para ver ahí
la cereza del postre y si como dice el
eslogan de un canal de televisión
pasa en el cine y pasa en la vida real
sin embargo neuquén hace poco sancionó
la ley de personalidad
esta ley prohíbe el uso de nombres e
imágenes en todo acto oficial o por caso
medellín acaba de sancionar una
ordenanza que obliga el uso de una única
marca a futuro que es el escudo de armas
seleccionado por concursos pero lo más
interesante es que los argumentos decía
para que los gobernantes tomen
conciencia del uso del presupuesto
público que debe ser destinado
preferentemente acciones sociales
y la verdad me encanta
en tercer lugar
frenar todo aquello que genere una
ciudadanía pasiva el slogan de un
pueblito en el norte argentino hace
tiempo era el intendente que quiere la
gente no es el intento que quiere a la
gente es la gente que lo quiera el
súbditos de un rey monarquías cuasi
monarquías y el ejemplo es electoral
pero sirve igual en méxico un gobernante
es llamado fidel ensalza un eslogan
buscando la mayoría en la cámara
legislativa que era tu fidelidad me
fortalece a mí gobernante monarca
lo que no les digo que se llama fidel y
tenía un 0-800 fidel en el gobierno y un
juego deportivo llamado copa fidelidad
ustedes escucharán seguramente incluso
en argentina es por destinados a las
personas de la tercera edad nunca se les
habla de ustedes son ellos nuestros
abuelos ellos cobrarán podrán con suerte
se les minimiza su capacidad receptiva y
ahí también hay ciudadanía pasiva y en
cuarto lugar es el estado peligroso
estereotipan t el estado discriminante
es un verdadero peligro cuando un estado
no escucha y es capaz de herir a
minorías
por diferencias de género
de profesiones de regiones de barrios
fíjense qué interesante que muchas veces
la desgracia es una especie de zanahoria
y la política pública del garrote como
pasa muchas veces cuando hay políticas
públicas destinadas
a frenar las desgracias de un barrio
pero primero se lo que ti fica se le
estigmatice y luego después viene la
política pública intentar solucionar o
por los casos o por caso con los ninis
en toda américa latina esta porción de
jóvenes estigmatizada que supuestamente
ni estudian ni trabajan hasta que un
organismo multilateral hace poco
acaba de sacar una estadística donde
dicen que es una ficción el número
inventado
porque más bien se trata de jóvenes que
tienen problemas de formalización de
precariedad laboral
y donde el 70% además son mujeres pero
se le estigmatiza para darle solución
hace días un presidente explicando
medidas para mitigar una crisis dijo que
preferentemente iban destinadas a la
clase media que siempre trabaja
y el resto y los que menos tienen eso
duele por lo tanto en estas prácticas
que tienen que ver con revisar los
protocolos que tiene que ver con frenar
el abuso de la personalización que tiene
que ver con frenar la generación de su
venia pasiva que tiene que ver con
ponerles límites a un estado
estigmatizante nos permiten salir si las
entendemos de este estado
que siempre habla hacia ellos que no
contiene que no incluye desde un yo
voluntarista personal asimétrico que
incluso cuando usa el nosotros lo hace
como cortesía del marketing o de la
publicidad
yo entiendo
que la comunicación no resuelve las
carencias pero tiene un poder simbólico
para acercar gobernantes y gobernados
para incluir antes que excluir joshua
dix tag
hablaba respecto a que el quijote no
tenía plena noción ni conciencia sobre
si va a ganar o sus chances de victoria
frente a la disputa contra los molinos
de viento pero lo hacía porque estaba
convencido y estoy convencido de esto
independientemente de las chances porque
intentar la regulación del estado la
autorregulación de los gobernantes
depende de que alguien pague costos
incluyendo el miedo me refiero los
gobernantes la regulación auto
regulación depende de que nos activemos
independientemente de que algunos
pudiésemos proponer todos pudiésemos
apoyar
se trata de un acto de docencia se trata
de activismo se trata de concientización
pero se trata básicamente de alertar que
la comunicación política no es ni más ni
menos que la propia política expresada
en su faz en su modo público por lo
tanto entender el peso de la
comunicación de los estados romper
contra esas inercias para que éstos
puedan incluir antes que excluir es
demasiado importante
saben como despertamos a los de arriba
si antes y con ganas y convencidos nos
despertamos primero todos nosotros
[Aplausos]
[Música]
ah